this rally in panama city is a
consequence of a collapsed deal between
a protest movement and the government
it aimed to reduce fuel prices in
exchange for ending two weeks of
demonstrations
[Music]
but these people are calling for fresh
action
the national coordinating committee of
indigenous peoples of panama call on the
entire indigenous population to a
national strike on thursday
the agreement was signed in cherokee
province last week it lowered the price
of fuel by about a third in exchange for
unblocking the pan-american highway a
crucial trade link
the protesters tore up the deal saying
paying less at the pump won't solve a
cost of living crisis or end corruption
banners like this are displayed across
roads this one calls for cheaper
medicine and justice for the poor
the international monetary fund says
recent figures show the economy is
improving since the pandemic but there
is still a high rate of inequality
and the protests are having a direct
impact on supermarket shelves
luckily we got tomatoes but no onions
there is a problem the one supermarket
here that sells vegetables and fruit has
practically closed
as you can see most of the stalls are
closed early because they don't have
anything to sell
let's hope the government and leaders
reach a solution soon protesters say
they will take to the streets until the
prices of basic goods are reduced
but with markets struggling to stock up
panama's four and a half million people
risk going hungry
manly al jazeera